well I'm delighted to say I'm joined Now
by Thomas hand and by his daughter Emily
so Thomas it's fantastic to see you both
it's great uh to see you because I I
guess because I'm a father I have a
12-year-old girl myself I'm Irish um and
so your story of so many stories in this
awful War resonated with me very
personally and I can't tell you how
thrilled I was when you were reunited
with Emily and let me start just by
asking you about that moment for you
what was it like for you to finally
after everything you'd been through
thinking she was dead then hearing she
might be alive then hearing she was
being released the moment that we all
watched on video when she ran towards
you what were you
thinking
H um it was it was
unbelievable uh it was a
Miracle um when we were waiting they
were supposed to have released her much
earlier than that during the day
according to our
agreements but uh we waited a long time
and uh during that time of course I'm
thinking something's gone wrong
something's going to go wrong either on
the Hamas side or on our own government
side the Israeli government side you
know you just until I saw
the color of her
eyes uh I could
not I couldn't hope I had to keep my
feelings and emotions
down I can see her sitting there she
doesn't speak much English um you
brought her up uh speaking Hebrew um but
she wanted to sit in on this interview
with you which I guess maybe an
indication just generally of not wanting
to leave your side very much how is how
has she been doing Emily since she got
back uh to be very honest she's doing
incredibly well um kids are just
amazingly
resilient um Her speech is almost back
at full volume she's eating like a horse
she sleeps well not not too many
nightmares um
baby
uh not too many
nightmares
um the occasional one but uh sometimes I
I just watch her in the night and uh
when I see
her crunching up her face I I wake her
up break the
Nightmare and how are you doing Thomas
because you've been through so much in
the last 100 days your peaceful life was
suddenly just thrown to pieces in so
many ways and I'll come to some of the
other ways that people may not even
realize but how how are you
doing um I'm actually doing very well
um I actually wasn't in a great position
before this all started mentally
depression um but because of it
all it's made me uh
Stronger uh if you can get through this
you can I can get through through
anything um Ken uh all the interviews
all the television interviews the
newspaper interviews you're you're
reliving not just that day my day
started the evening
before um so I'm living from the 6th the
evening of the 6th to whenever the
interview took place like I'm maybe
going to have to relive it again for you
from the 6 till this date and so I was
at one point
talking 12 hours a day every day of the
week and uh that's basically what you do
in therapy it was a free free
Psychotherapy so I'm much
stronger I'm I'm so glad to hear that
and how fascinating that I guess it's it
jolted your life in a way that changed
everything um and I'm very glad for you
that it's it seems to have had a
positive impact after all the horror let
me take you then back to October the 6th
uh what was your life like at that
moment I know that very sadly your wife
had died of cancer Emily's mother and
you've been bringing her up uh what I
didn't know actually was that you were
sharing a lot of of the kind of
parenting duties with your ex-wife who
who um stepped in and and helped you
which I thought was an extraordinary
thing she tragically was killed on
October the 7th but we'll come to that
but on October the 6th how would you
describe your your
life um I've said it before but
uh I I I came to Israel when I was 32 in
um from the moment I woke up in the
morning uh there was sunshine you know
you come from England and everything is
gray and
horrible uh started meeting the people
of the
kibuts uh they're all just lovely honest
people
um and then when I found out that they
they were socialist and it it was
socialism at work and actually working I
was uh I was blown away cuz uh I've been
a socialist practically all my life uh
so I thought yeah this is great and then
and then I went I met
niss and uh yeah she was just gorgeous
um calm
patient uh I thought yeah I like this
I'm going to
stay on octob the
7th I know that we know now that Emily
of course was having a sleepover with
her friend Hiller um and her mother was
to play a very important role with what
then happened with Emily and we'll come
to that but what was your first inkling
that something very bad was going
down
okay um
right
um yeah it was it was Instinct it was uh
there was no uh there was no way to work
out something like that was happening it
was just it was a a feeling a feeling of
dread something not right on that day um
for since we pulled out of Gaza in
2005 we've been peppered hammered with
um Kasam Rock KS from
Gaza all the
time um and we're used to that we just
get the we get the
siren we got it's saber adom it comes
over the whole intercom um
connections even on your phone saor ad
Dom saor ad Dom means it's red color so
wherever you are you look for the
nearest uh bomb shelter and get there
pretty Swift ly we have uh in kibuts we
have 11
seconds which isn't a long time but you
don't panic and we at first you panicked
you ran like the clappers but
um as the years go by you just drop
everything in a second there's no Panic
you just swiftly get there um 11 seconds
is quite a long
time and when was the moment you
realized this was not just a
regular situation that this was
something completely horrific
MH right yeah well uh after the bombing
stopped uh the missiles
stopped um I was already in my safe room
the buom shelter and uh I had the door
open we don't normally close it and I
could hear uh shooting
automatic rifles gun fire machine
guns uh still hearing bombs booms going
off I think they were looking back there
were
RPGs um and it was all just it was all
just too close we're we're used to the
sound of all the sounds of War where we
live and uh this was just unnatural it
wasn't right and it was getting closer
very
rapidly um every
minute
obviously you weren't with Emily did you
try and get hold of her did you know
what was
happening uh when I when the penny
started to drop what the hell was going
on um the first thing was uh I rang my
ex-wife
niss made sure she was in the bomb
shelter of course she was in the bump
shelter but I I made I told her close
your door we most of us don't ever close
the door there's no need they weren't
built for
this type of incursion anyway um so I
told her close your door and push the
handle locked as far as you
can and hold on to it for dear life as
hard and as long as you
can um I told NIS to ring Rya the mother
of the friend that she was staying at um
the same instructions give it to
Ria um Ria's hearings not so great her
hearings um was damaged when she was
born uh and I wanted this information to
be relayed perfectly to her I didn't
want any
mistakes the full horror of what is
actually
unfurling took quite a while to be
understood by people the kind of
medieval barbarism that was going on but
what was the moment Thomas for you that
you realized that Emily was
gone
um not for a few days later my I'm sorry
but my time scale is uh completely
gone uh these last three months seemed
like a year already so I have no time
reference anymore but uh within a week I
was informed that
um uh she'd been found dead in the
HEBs and there there was an
extraordinary interview that you gave to
Clarissa Ward at CNN I know Clarissa
used to work with her and I want to just
play a little clip from that this was
when you belied that Emily had been
killed they just said we found
Emily uh she's dead
and I went
yes that was the best possibil that I
was hoping for she was either
dead or in
Gaza and if you know anything about what
they do to people in
Gaza that is worse than death so death
was a blessing an absolute
blessing that was such an agonizing
interview to watch Thomas can you
remember yeah your feelings at that at
that point when you really did think
you'd lost her I completely understood
what you were saying but can you
remember how you
felt yeah absolutely relieved because um
in a way it was very uh prophetic and
I'm sure half the people well 90% of the
people in the world would not realize
what I was saying um how bad the Kamas
can treat treat their
hostages uh and yes death was much
better than anything that they were
going to do to her she was at peace she
was at rest I could be resting I could
be at peace I could just do the natural
process of grieving instead of what
139 hostages are held still there so all
the families and all the friends are
going through that now thankfully I
didn't have to go through that I went
through it for almost two months but
they're still there 100 days 1001 days
now and you know Thomas even as I'm I'm
speaking to you I've just been sent a
note that two more hostages have now
been confirmed to have been killed um
that's just been breaking news as I'm
talking to you which just goes to show
that the the horror of people who've now
had to wait 100 days and then to get
news like that it is it's unimaginable
to me what everyone in that position
must be going
through yeah it's an absolute nightmare
um sorry but do you do you have their
names at all yes I do I've just been
sent it now um Hamas has released a
video appearing to show bodies of two
hostages um Yosi sharabi and itai zki
who appeared alive in a
video it was they were in a video
released by the group
yesterday um in a new video the third
hostage Noah Aram aramani says the peir
were killed because of Israeli air
strikes she was obviously speaking as a
hostage herass has produced no evidence
for that claim um but this follows that
video they released
yesterday
so Noah Noah is
gone it seems that Noah's alive and was
making the video
announcement that the other two had ah
died at the hands of an Israeli air
strike right yeah
um Ellie no it wasn't Ellie it was Yosi
Yosi yes Yosi shabi and spki again they
they they they were from kibot
ber and uh sersi was with Emily for the
whole duration of her captivity there
was nothing wrong with
him so they've killed
him okay and of course blaming the IDF
why why wouldn't you yeah well thank god
Noah is
alive and hopefully she will stay that
way so yeah and Noah's mother such a
such
a yeah I'm very I'm so sorry to have had
to told you that I just felt it was
important given you were just talking
directly about the hostages that you
should be aware of that
news oh Christ yeah and you
know uh Yosi um his brother is there as
well Ellie or he's already dead I don't
know but
um Ellie uh he saw probably saw his wife
being shot to to death and uh his
16-year-old daughter and his 13-year-old
daughter the Noya and
yel
sharabi and
lean so yeah that's a hell of a tragedy
that's that's
yeah that's that's almost a whole family
wiped out
horrific absolutely
horrific Thomas let me let me take you
back I'm sure I'm sure they're going to
say the IDF did it of course they're
going to say that yeah I mean we don't
know the full facts yet obviously this
is all a Hamas video and they've
obviously made Noah say this and we'll
hopefully get more information about
this uh over the next day or two but um
appalling news obviously on the day of
everyone looking at the 100 days since
hostages were taken two more confirmed
to have died and that's just uh
indicative of the horror that the poor
families are going through and what you
would have still been going through had
Emily not been released let me take you
back Thomas
to when you discovered that Emily may be
still alive you weren't even certain but
you were told there were indications
that she might be still
alive yeah uh yeah at the at the time it
was uh it was the lack of evidence that
she was dead that uh there was three
stages you were either
dead uh Missing because they didn't know
where you were or confirmed as a hostage
taken away and uh because she was no
longer dead they didn't find her body
anywhere they didn't find any DNA so you
have to
presume she's missing and
probably only probably hostage in Gaza
but then uh later
on uh funny enough on the night of a
ceremony honoring the hostages some an
eyewitness came up to us someone we knew
and said she saw
Emily hila her friend and Rya the mother
being led away to Gaza put in the back
of a truck and uh taken away so that's
when she she went through the whole
Spectrum she was dead she was missing
and then she became a hostage in
Gaza and for you having already told the
world that you would have preferred to
think that she was dead than being held
hostage that emotion for you when you
realize your worst
fear may actually now have been realized
what was that life
fory
um yeah that was uh that was like being
punched into the stomach by Mike Tyson
um no take his name out that that was
like being punched in the stomach by a
professional
boxer
um yeah um your heart sank your mind
went into uh overload of what's going to
happen to her um yeah that was a that
was the worst moment out of it all the
worst just falling into that bottomless
pit of despair Ken that was
awful and the greatest Moment For You by
contrast must have been the moment that
you were told that she was going to be
released how did you hear
that yeah it was sort of funny in a
way um
okay we're all all everyone from bar
more or less everyone from bar is in the
hotel David in and the in the Dead Sea
that's our base the majority majority of
us are
there and uh the hotel has been
absolutely fantastic they they've
welcomed us with open arms they've LED
our dogs and animals into the hotel
we're ruining it basically but they've
they don't care they they just they've
welcomed us and
Kim if you can you imagine a festar
hotel with dogs running around it's
bizarre when you see it anyway
um car well done to them um so yeah so
I'm sitting in the in
the in the David Hotel outside on a
chair and uh funnny enough I had a
reporter sitting right next to me he
was not exactly an interview but a pre-
inter and um I got a phone call from the
Army saying Emily's on the
list and you can imagine I wanted to
scre I wanted to jump up and
scream and I had to just keep absolutely
calm and collected and say okay right uh
thank you very much for that information
uh I'll get back back to you some
I didn't there no way I wanted
the reporter to get a hint of what was
going on um and thankfully he didn't and
uh as soon as I once I got back to the
hotel room I think I screamed the blue
murder
yeah I can't even imagine and after all
the emotions you've gone through and all
the differing thought processes to
finally be told that she might be
imminently released and yet I guess as
you said at the start of the interview
with a caveat that you couldn't be
entirely sure until he saw
her
no yep um it was a an unbelievable
moment like I say uh and thank God I was
lucky enough to have that moment we're
still waiting for other families to have
that
moment and hopefully it will come to
them
too
uh the the reality Thomas of what she'd
been through was nowhere near as
horrific as you had
feared um I I don't want to speak for
you but my understanding is there was no
sign that she had been beaten or abused
in any way um I think that's that's the
case
right yep um as far as terrorists go
they were uh reasonably good
uh they didn't sexually abuse her like
they've done with many
others she wasn't raped even as a small
child which they have done to others she
wasn't beaten
tortured um they
were they were all reasonably Humane
shall we say um they they kept them on
very small rations of
food even though they had lots of food
in my head I'm thinking you know she's
not going to be getting lots of food
because probably they won't have lots of
food but um she's told me that uh no
they had lots of food they could smell
it being cooked but they weren't given
any one day they built like they made a
a mountain of like very small
donuts a mountain of them and they they
each had uh they were given one each no
need for
that anyway
she you found that she her head was full
of lice for example and she was pretty
emaciated given how she had been before
um but was the biggest problem that she
faced and you faced
psychological you know I I read that she
believed she'd actually been taken for a
year oh yeah but you know the old saying
uh when you're having fun time flies and
uh I guess her two months felt like a
year she wasn't enjoying it very much
yeah um most of the time they the only
um activity that they could do was uh
play cards and uh do drawing they had to
be very very quiet there was no
conversations uh so that that would get
boring after a very short
time they were threatened at one stage
with knife by one of the Hamas
terrorists because they were making too
much
noise uh yeah they were probably just
talking they weren't making much noise
but they were told to be be
quiet um yeah be quiet or we'll we'll
kill you with this knife is what she
said to me how do how do you say be
quiet how how do you say t
Arab
what good she's learned Arabic while she
was away so that's you know that's
always a good thing isn't it that's
amazing amazing kids I mean like you say
kids are I've got four kids they are
incredibly resilient children even in
the face of such extraordinary adversity
I believe that Emily was moved around
with the other hostages that she was
with including her friend heila and of
course Rea heer's mother uh and that
they were at one stage uh a b landed
very very close to where they were
shattering Windows sending fragments of
glass all over the sofa where they where
they were a very narrow Escape by the
sound of
it uh yep yep um they were all very
lucky of course
um again after after uh let's say at
least a month of running from the north
towards the South um running as far away
from the IDF as possible possible uh
they were a they were finally able to
settle
down uh sleep on something soft instead
of the the hard
ground and
uh I don't know at what point in time it
happened but uh yeah a bomb fell close
by
uh and uh the windows
shattered and uh unfortunately after
that as well the uh because the window
was shattered and it was cold at the
time not as cold as it is now but um
they they put blankets up to stop the
cold from coming in and of course that
diminished a lot of their
light um so she came back uh very very
white the um lady that I think you feel
you are a great deal of debt to is Ray
rotm who uh effectively acted like like
Emily's mom as she was with her own
daughter who was with her they'd all
been together of course for that
sleepover Rhea was not released at the
same time as the girls um which was
another cruelty by herass but it did
eventually come out several days later
have you been able to I'm sure you have
but have you been able to reflect to her
how much you appreciate what she did for
your daughter in that horrendous
captivity uh yeah yeah we've met a few
times
um uh she's in
uh she's in a different place from the
Dead Sea to me and uh but we've met a
few times uh where she's living and um
in Tel
Aviv uh sometimes she gets a a break at
the weekend and she can come come up to
Tel Aviv and have a little bit of
fun
the well there were other tragedies for
you uh your your ex-wife narcis was
killed on October the 7th and was the
mother of of your two other children um
and you had to explain that I guess to
Emily when she came back she'd acted
like a another mother to her that must
have been an incredibly difficult thing
to
do
yeah uh yeah when she was
released um and after all the hugs and
the celebrations together uh we were put
in a a transport Convoy uh coming back
to the hospital to get her treated for
whatever injuries she might have and
check her physically all over and
mentally anyway
um so I said to her
uh Aiden and Natalie my two oldest kids
and uh her grandmother Mariana are
waiting in the in the
hospital with uh our other dog
schnitzel uh they're going to meet you
when we get there and she's uh she's
very smart she immediately went what
about
niss so um
I I was I was shocked I wasn't ready for
that so I said uh uh we don't know about
niss yet just anything to keep her away
because uh I wanted to get back to the
hospital and speak to the psychiatrist
first to ask what am I supposed to do
what what should I
say and uh I knew the answer already
I've I've been there with her actual
mother uh the best thing you can do is
tell them the truth as hard and painful
is is to do for you and for them that's
what you've got to do so um she asked
two more times in the van going back to
the hospital and I had to just keep her
at Bay eventually we got back to the
hospital they said yes you just got to
tell her
so sat her down quietly and uh just told
her straight and uh the only reaction
she had at the time was uh very sharp in
intake of breath she just
went and that was it didn't say a word
only the next night um
she she uh sobbed herself to sleep but
under the blankets on the bed like under
the duvet on on the bed um obviously the
first thing you want to do is Comfort
your child
she wouldn't let me touch her she'd
forgotten how to be comforted by a
parent and that was that was very hard I
just had to um had to let her cry it
out it's incredibly touching Thomas to
watch the way Emily has been interacting
with you throughout this interview and
not least just then when she wiped away
your tears um she's an extraordinary
young young girl isn't
she she's tougher than all of us she
really is tougher than all of us um I'm
not bad I'm very emotional
as right the way through it I've always
been emotional I'm sorry about that but
uh that's me um but she's as uh she's as
tough as Nails God
lover you also lost uh one of your best
friends Leanne on October the 7th as
well
yeah yeah that
that's that's uh Yosi shab's
sister-in-law yeah so if you count them
all up it's uh yel 13 yel
shabi Noya shabi
16 Leanne to be honest I don't know her
age um
50 her husband taken hostage whether
he's still alive or not I don't know and
his brother
Yosi who's now
dead it just goes on and on and that's
not the only family does um does another
family on the kibuts de a family
again the husband are on the
asmin they kids and a brother all dead
all dead they're civilians they didn't
do anything to
anyone they just happened to get be
there in the in in in the crosshairs of
the
day absolutely
horrendous um I understand that Leanne's
parents rang you or sent you a WhatsApp
message I think to wish you a happy
Christmas and you were just struck by
how they could find the strength to
think of anything like
that yeah uh you know it's Christmas our
best
holiday
um you you put on for for the kids we
put on a happy
face tried to make the most of it I went
back to berry kots berry to get my uh
Christmas tree and
decorations uh I could have I could have
gone out and bought my own um you know
new ones but no I I wanted I wanted my
ones from the
kots so uh me and my son Aiden went back
to the
kots loaded up the car brought it back
and uh you know prepared for Christmas
Day and uh yeah I'm pretty sure it was
on Christmas day
um and Pete sent a WhatsApp you know I
know them very very well um wishing me
and our family a happy Christmas that's
astounding to have the strength and
courage to wish somebody else a happy
day when you when you are having the
worst Christmas of your
life how can you do that I didn't know
what to say
back what what answer do you give
because the normal answer is yeah happy
Christmas to you too and a Happy New
Year I can what can you
say I literally texted them back saying
I have nothing to say I can't I can't I
have no reply to
that it's quite extraordinary that they
would find the strength to do that yeah
Thomas how do you feel incredible about
how do you feel about the general
situation now 100 days on from the
appalling Terror attacks that hit you
and so many families how do you feel
about the debate about the war itself
about Israel's response some people
feeling it's it's become
disproportionate because so many
civilians have being killed what do you
feel about
that H they don't know a
thing
um
you they
we are living it okay we are living it
we have been living it every day for 20
years you have no idea you have no right
to even speak to me have you been to
Israel
ever any one of you saying it's
disproportionate has any one of you come
to see a path hiide in this country it
doesn't exist you OT it doesn't
exist look at all the road signs come
come and look at all the road
signs it's in Hebrew it's in Arabic and
it's in English all the buses all the
buses with the electronic writing have
Hebrew Arabic and English do you
honestly think the country would go to
that much trouble having all the road
signs in all three
languages it was wouldn't if we were a
pared you wouldn't do that you wouldn't
waste your money for crying out
loud come to come to any Hospital in
this in this country come to any school
in this country come to any City in this
country you'll
find
Arabs women female Arabs professors in
hospitals
everywhere
doctors you're
talking out of your bottoms you have no
idea you have no idea and you're all
chanting from The River To The Sea you
don't know what
river you don't know your history you
don't know your
geography because they're saying from
The River To The Sea well if you had any
idea of geography you could work out
where this little country is and go oh
it's the Mediterranean Sea but they
don't know that
educated Harvard students University
students I'm sorry you can cut out the
Harvard bit educated Harvard educated
University students and they don't even
know what river or what sea
borders
Israel yeah they're probably very
educated in their specific subject but
don't know anything else around
it there are people Thomas who who
believe that the stories from October
the 7th have been exaggerated that much
of it didn't happen you know so many
people directly impacted by what did
happen that day it was in your home yeah
what do you say to people who want to
deny what
happened sorry could you go again on
that
one there are some people many people
actually who want to try and downplay
what happened on October the 7th who
think the stories have been exaggerated
that women weren't raped that people
weren't beheaded that you know
everything has been exaggerated what do
you say to
them um what do I say to them it it
really doesn't matter what I say does it
it really doesn't matter what I
say all the
footage that that you see of that day
and days afterwards that's Hamas body
cams that's Hamas body cams they were
streaming it they were proud of
it you want to
go actually I just wanted to ask her one
question Thomas before she goes can we
just ask em something sorry
sorry yeah okay I just wanted to ask
Emily one question has she G or can we
ask her one question
oh
right one
second
uh if you could just ask a Thomas fire
away ask Emily I just wanted to for you
to ask her that moment when she saw you
again what was that moment like for
her uh y that's a quite an important
moment very good question
um initially it uh you know it was hugs
and kisses and happiness and everything
like that but uh then I realized she was
looking at me in a funny
way so
I questioned her I said what what what's
on your mind what's going
on uh
you she had actually
presumed that uh I was either killed or
being held hostage and she kept looking
at me to make sure it was
me um because that's what she saw on
that day on the 7th it was Midday she
saw dead bodies on her way out to go
and other people being taken hostage and
put in the back of the truck so she
presumed that's what happened to
everyone on the kbooks and I hadn't even
that thought had not occurred to me
whatsoever
so what's your actual question because
that be if you could just ask if you
could ask Emily if you could just ask
her how did she feel when she saw you
and realized you were alive and you were
there for
her uh
happy happy she says
happy you know what that's all she
needed to say I'm and it's been uh and
she
[Music]
smiled
yeah she was she says she was very happy
and and smiled yeah I think that's all
she needed to all she needs to say and
it was wonderful to hear it Thomas I've
got to leave it there thank you so much
for your time for you and for Emily I
can't tell you how happy I am uh that
you guys are sitting there able to do
this interview after all you went
through and I really appreciate your
time thank you